hey youtubers is Charlie so Sherlock
season 4 is getting ready to start on
January 1st on the BBC and PBS
so I'm teaming up with my friends at BBC
Worldwide just to explain what's going
on and everything that's happened so far
so Sherlock is finally back the first
episode is gonna be airing January 1st
on the BBC and PBS in the United States
each episode after that episodes two and
three there's three episodes total will
air the week after that so January 1st
January 8th and then the 15th so if it's
been a long time since you've watched or
you've never watched Sherlock and you
have no idea what's going on I'm gonna
recap like the first three seasons and
the specials just to explain what's been
happening in what's going on so no
worries no spoilers for season four and
I'll add links to the trailers that they
posted on the Sherlock YouTube channel
at the end of this so if you've never
watched Sherlock before Benedict
Cumberbatch you probably know as Doctor
Strange little movie that just came out
Martin Freeman was also in Captain
America Civil War so there's kind of a
Marvel and a Sherlock reunion happening
at the same time here which is really
funny before season 1 aired there
weren't that many people outside of the
UK that knew who they were but it was
almost like the big seismic shift after
Robert Downey jr. started doing Iron Man
Marvel movies like suddenly everybody
was paying attention to them so they
just blew up big time
I'll go episode by episode but largely
season 1 is just the coming together of
Sherlock and Watson like the story of
how they first met in how they started
solving crimes together
Moriarty didn't really manifest till the
end of the season season two was more
Moriarty heavy but because of the way
they structure episodes some of them
will be mythology episodes where you'll
have like this overarching storyline of
Sherlock versus Moriarty and some of
them will be more standalone
like Hound of Baskerville so let's just
go through the episodes starting with
episode 1 a study in pink
Sherlock meets dr. Watson for the first
time so the main adventure of this story
is Sherlock and Watson solving a series
of murders where people seem to have
died by taking a poison pill they find
the person that's behind the pills
that's compelled these people to take
these is actually himself being
controlled
I Moriarty in a very Princess Bride
Poisson standoff between Sherlock in the
serial killer he is saved by Watson who
shoots the serial killer proving what a
badass he is but they're lauded as
heroes by the police department they
sort of proved their worth in or allowed
to continue solving cases the episode
does a brilliant job of setting the
characters up explaining their
personalities
you literally meet Sherlock for the
first time as he's beating a corpse but
the whole idea here is just them
beginning their day-to-day of solving
mysteries Watson blogging about it he
has a blog in the original Arthur Conan
Doyle stories that the episodes are
adapted from Watson in a very meta way
is writing the stories after they've
happened so as you're reading The
Adventures of Sherlock Holmes it's
almost like it was written by Watson
himself so on the TV show the form that
takes is the blog that begins to take
off so over the course of the first
couple seasons they turn into internet
celebrities which they later turn into a
big twist in season 2 which I'll explain
in a second the second episode the blind
banker is more of a deep dive into
Sherlock deciphering codes and symbols
you start to learn more about the mind
Palace is an international smuggling
operation he finds out that the blind
banker himself was killed because he
stole something in the process of
smuggling illegal goods so Sherlock runs
afoul of a gang called the Black Lotus
tong but then later we find out that
Moriarty was again pulling the strings
under the name of someone called M so at
the end of the episode we still haven't
seen his face the third episode the
great game is the first time we actually
get to see Moriarty in the flesh he
finally steps out this is where it gets
a little meta because Sherlock has to
recover some secret government plans for
a very important project but at the same
time is challenged by Moriarty to solve
a series of crimes where he's rigged
different people with exploding vests if
he doesn't solve the mystery they go
boom Sherlock finally learns how they're
all connected recovers the plans but in
doing so it throws him into Moriarty's
path so just as Sherlock is getting
ready to blow them all up to defeat
Moriarty Moriarty gets a phone call from
someone that in
that being a season 2 teaser for that
first episode that I'll explain in a
second but they've had their first
standoff the unstoppable force meets the
immovable object sort of a rain check
that they give each other on the
apocalypse that they were going to rain
down so season 2 episode 1 we learned
that Moriarty when he was talking to
Sherlock when they were getting ready to
blow each other up was Irene Adler who
was calling him because she had leverage
on one of the royal family members so
the episode is all about scandals
there's the smaller plot getting the
scandalous photos of the royal back from
Irene Adler but then it becomes
something much bigger because Irene
Adler has evidence of a huge government
cover-up in going back and forth of the
episode we learned that Sherlock and
Irene Adler have a weird sexual
obsession with each other that kind of
continues in the background in future
seasons another big change now during
season two is that because Sherlock is
aware of Moriarty he's ever-present in
the episode he sits across from Sherlock
he taunts him they're playing their game
eventually they capture him but then
later release him in the second episode
episode 2 Hound of Baskerville is more
of a standalone episode not so much
about Moriarty even though he is and he
gets released but it's mostly about this
chemical weapons program that Sherlock
finds out about that has the acronym
Hound so that's where the Hound of
Baskerville comes from episode 3 the
Reichenbach Fall
now that Moriarty has been released from
the government facility he's free to go
after Sherlock enforces him to commit
suicide or else all of his friends will
die so Moriarty has created a situation
whereby he kills himself but his agents
will still kill all of Sherlock's
friends if he doesn't throw himself off
the building so Sherlock has to come up
with a plan to fulfill the terms of that
bargain while at the same time not
killing himself
so season 2 - season 3 was this big
mystery because Sherlock seemingly
killed himself he stepped off the
building at the end of the episode but
then they cut to black so earlier I
mentioned that Watson's blog turned them
into internet celebrities this is where
they pick up with the blog coming into
season 3 there was like a short episode
where Sherlock was like hey everybody
I'm back so season 3 the
stree was how did he survive and part of
the fun of the episode was the idea that
this cult of Sherlock had risen in his
absence everybody thinking that maybe
he's dead maybe he's not dead here are
all the different ways that he could
have survived so it's been about two
years that everyone thought that
Sherlock was dead
Watson's moved on with his life and he
is now engaged to Mary Morstan they're
getting ready to get married so if you
don't know her she's a big figure from
the Canon that becomes Watson's wife and
helps him as he's writing The Adventures
of Sherlock Holmes so Mary becomes a big
part of the season three cast in all the
episodes she has her own secrets that we
learn about over the course of the three
episodes but she becomes a very
important figure in what used to be this
two-person partnership so a lot of the
comedy flows from Sherlock just getting
used to there being like a third wheel
now in their little group but eventually
we learn about a new overarching villain
because Moriarty is arguably dead like
Sherlock saw him shoot himself in the
head so there's still a lot of theories
about how he could possibly survive but
the new Big Bad of season 3 was Augustus
Magnussen this sort of evil media Baron
who just had control of tons and tons of
information and also had a mind Palace
like the ability to hold and process
information just as well as Sherlock so
he slowly manifests but they don't
really face off to the 3rd episode the
second episode the sign of three is more
of a comedy about the wedding of Marion
Watson but at the end Sherlock learns
that Mary is pregnant they all learned
that she's pregnant so the baby itself
becomes this ticking time bomb that's
getting ready to go off in series four
but the final episode is Sherlock vs
Magnussen this big bad for season three
so his big thing is blackmail he has
this media empire like imagine him being
the head of something like Facebook so
he has all this information that could
hurt everyone he uses it to get people
to do what he wants people in positions
of power people in Parliament the only
recourse Sherlock can find is to kill
him before he could harm anyone else so
Sherlock is now a murderer being
arrested in carted off
but at the very end there's this teaser
as Sherlock's being flown away they make
you feel like this is the end of their
partnership this is the end of Sherlock
but just as the plane is getting ready
to take off everywhere all over London a
message of Moriarty pops up on digital
screens just all over the city saying
did you miss me so the government is
forced to bring Sherlock back to help
solve this new mystery but then in real
life because there was so much time
between season 3 in now season 4 which
were getting ready for of Sherlock they
did a Christmas special last year
instead of doing new episodes but it was
like a full episode so the teaser was is
that they were doing an episode of
Sherlock in full period in 1895 with all
the same actors all the same characters
so normally sure like I said in present
day so it was really just like everybody
taken back to the 1890s and they were
gonna do a Sherlock mystery but then at
the end the big twist is that we find
Sherlock has been inside his mind palace
this whole episode has taken place in
Sherlock's mind with him trying to learn
how Moriarty could have survived because
we thought he was dead for the entirety
of season 3 so now part of the fun of
series 4 is gonna be answering that
question in the first episode like
what's going on who's the new villain
what was happening with Moriarty's
picture popping up all over London
simultaneously so what's going to happen
is is I'll be doing videos for each of
the episodes but here's the thing like I
know you've waited a long time for
series 4 to get here but the episodes
are a full 90 minutes which is basically
like a small movie for each episode it's
huge it's way bigger than a normal
episode of an hour-long drama so if
you've never watched Sherlock before
it's kind of like watching a movie for
each episode so there's a serialized
plot that sort of runs in the background
of each of the episodes with like
Sherlock vs the big bat but then within
each episode there are a bunch of
smaller mysteries that he has to solve
so I don't need to tell you how
fantastic Benedict Cumberbatch and
Martin Freeman are they're two amazing
actors especially when they're doing
Sherlock so if you've never watched it
before I would recommend that you watch
at least a couple episodes just to get
yourself ready and then watch series 4
starting on January 1st so like I said
I'll be posting episode videos in the
official Sherlock YouTube channel will
be posting a bunch of
clips and behind-the-scenes stuff
interviews with the actors on their
YouTube channel so I'll post links to
that at the end of this while you guys
wait for that to post you can click here
to rewatch the season 4 trailer on their
channel and you can click here for all
the other interviews and
behind-the-scenes stuff they've been
posting thank you so much for watching
everybody let's high five I'll see you
guys tonight